I'm now in the Rhine mine reach in one
of Germany's biggest metropolitan areas
but I'm still rolling through places
that could almost be villages I now have
1623 kilometres two-thirds of the
distance behind me and with 53 days
two-thirds of the time as well let's
hope the trip takes the 80 days I
planned Indy spot in the capital of the
state of Hessen i discovered the Herla
Canaille a museum of humor and i asked
myself what is it about the german sense
of humor devoting a museum to it doesn't
sound very funny and Germans aren't
exactly considered world champions in
the Lapps department according to a
worldwide survey among 30,000 Internet
users the Americans took first place the
Spanish took second and the Italians got
bronze Germany ended up in 15th and last
place in the sense of humor sweepstakes
despite that crushing defeat seventy-two
percent of Germans think they have a
good sense of humor and only nine
percent say they have none what a
contradiction okay maybe it's not that
funny in Germany so let's see if we can
do it better in a museum
member
a few things look amusing but is it
really that funny in here I asked the
museum director me child Bagga how can
you capture humor in a museum in by
making your hands on because your mind
will grasp what you can grasp with your
hand hbu how often do you laugh here in
the museum might laugh whenever I'm here
seen statistically that's a lot for
Germany Germans in general spend only
six minutes a day laughing 40 years ago
that figure was 18 minutes oh well life
just keeps getting more serious okay if
we don't laugh a lot at least I want to
know what makes us laugh do we laugh
about ourselves or it up Oh everybody
said about the bed my first test subject
thinks my pratfalls pretty funny
the next seemed shocked to be amused and
then there's your enjoyment to 21 it's
not surprising shot employ de is a
German word and i'm sore from falling
down but how about laughing at ourselves
my first subject keeps a very straight
face but here's a person who can laugh
about herself and here's another so 2214
self-mockery we Germans seemed to laugh
at both others and our own misfortunes
okay we will finally get everybody to
laugh after all supposedly laughter is
contagious ready set go
deadly silence interesting maybe we
Germans aren't humorless we just don't
laugh that much I bet a lap in any case
now it's off to the south at the
breakneck speed of 12 kilometers an hour